salut peuple d internet
aujourd'hui nous entrons dans le système
dans la matrice dans le morse en fait on
va pas appeler de code morse
je ne sais pas si vous êtes déjà
intéressé au code morse mais forcément
comme tous les trucs un peu secret je
les trucs à comprendre me suis intéressé
un moment donné de ma vie et j'ai même
chercher récemment comment est-ce qu'on
pouvait apprendre le code morse donc le
code morse pour ce vraiment qu'ils ne
connaissent pas ce sont que des sons
cours ou rapide nous affaiblir groupe
mais c'est à dire que le grip est trois
fois plus long que le bipe
et il ya toujours un petit espace aussi
entre chaque code de l'être exemple
concret le eux c'est un beat bref et le
tessin à mi lourds le s et 3000 cours
bip bip bip le haut ses trois buts on me
dit oui parce qu'ils nous donnent
sos impayés bibitte bibi bibi libye
voilà vous êtes encore là c'est
intéressant
donc si un code qui a été énormément
utilisé par l'armée est encore utilisé à
ce jour
et forcément les militaires apprennent
ce code alors attention
loin de moi l'idée de faire une blague
du style si de militaires peuvent
l'apprendre par coeur on doit être nous
aussi capable de l'apprendre
parce que ce serait pas bien comme dit
ma gueule je le pense pas du tout en
plus je me suis demandé quel était leur
processus d'apprentissage parce que moi
vraiment basiquement pour apprendre du
morse
je me serais dit ok je vais faire
quelque chose dans l'imagination pour
avoir sa de standards ise dans mon
esprit et savoir si le le
le à aider je sais que c'est bref plus
le puil longue derrière bref du stockage
de données
une espèce de data avec tous les
symboles et la correspondance mais c'est
pas si simple que ça pour le traduire en
temps réel d'exécution donc j'ai regardé
des vidéos de l'armée je vous mets un
lien dans la description sur leur
système d'apprentissage qui en fait
assez intéressant parce qu'il est
synesthésique c'est à dire qu'on apprend
à la fois le code
brut on sait que l'on est bref par
exemple c'est le n
mais en même temps on apprend alors
reconnaître à l'oreille à le traduire
donc il ya la mémoire auditive avec
toute la compréhension et la mémoire
visuelle qui se met en marche en même
temps et j'ai fait des exercices que je
vous mets dans la description à savoir
de noter ce que j'entendais et au départ
on note vraiment des traits et des
points et au fur et à mesure mais assez
rapidement on s'aperçoit qu'on est des
lettres donc on est sur une traduction
instantanée
du coup j'ai fait des recherches et je
pense sincèrement qu'il ya pas de
meilleure méthode d'apprentissage du
morse que la méthode qu'utilise les
militaires du coup je n'avais pas de
quoi en faire une vidéo c'est pour ça
que vous en parle aujourd'hui juste
comme ça je vais pas faire une vidéo sur
quelque chose qui existe déjà et qui est
plus performante une méthode que
j'aurais pu trouver mais ça me permet de
vous parler d'un bouquin que j'ai bien
aimé qui est sorti ya pas si longtemps
que ça et attention comme d'habitude ce
n'est pas un placement produit s'est
acheté avec mes petits sous et c'est
pour ça que je ne fais pas gagné parce
que je le garde ça s'appelle fou de code
secret c'est un très bon livre ans qui
habitait chez flammarion et à
l'intérieur de ce livre il y à 50 code
secret qui sont repris décrypter
expliqué et en plus de ça il ya pas mal
de plus en plus du style l'historique
des codes secrets parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est le contexte il ya des
chapitres entiers qui sont consacrés aux
décrypteurs célèbres comme turing par
exemple le plus célèbre d'entre eux avec
toute leur histoire avec les anecdotes à
l'intérieur c'est assez imagé c'est
assez bien expliqué j'ai l'impression
d'être une jupe tube botella les gardes
le vous voyez ce que je veux dire
si vous voulez un petit bouquin les
jaliya et référentiels des 50 principaux
codes secrets c'est celui que je vous
recommande
j'en ai d'autres qui sont plus lourd
plus complexe donc aussi plus
intéressant et plus poussée mais c'est
pas forcément ce qu'on cherche qu on
veut avoir une vision complète des codes
secrets
je vous le dis l'année prochaine je vais
recréer une énigme et
il sera basé sur les codes secrets que
j'aurais réexploiter de ce bouquin la
voilà à quoi peut servir un bouquin
comme ça ou juste conclu au rejet des
plutôt léger foehn algues vient dans la
description bien sûr il ya également à
la fin d'un chapitre que consacrer sur
l'avenir des codes secrets et là je
trouvais ça intéressant tu es ce que on
parle toujours des anciens est rarement
des nouveaux jets la cryptographie
quantique et je ne vous en dis pas plus
vous trouverez ça là dedans si jamais
c'est à dire un sujet qui vous intéresse
comme d'habitude penser à la ligue est
née la vidéo et vous abonner si c'est
pas encore fait n'hésitez pas à explorer
l'espace description du commentaire vous
trouverez aussi un autre idée de noël
des places pour l'olympia mon lit mon
jeu est ce que tu veux toi même tu sais
je te laisse t'embrasser toi même
puisque j'ai pas le temps d'aller faire
une bise à tous ceux du grand cette
vidéo mais rendez vous demain à 6 heures
du matin pour la 5ème ouverture de ce
calendrier de l'avent du mental bloc de
chez pas quoi de toi même tu sais de
charme
et